si la brand n'est pas une habituée des
manifestations mais celles-ci elle ne
l'aurait raté pour rien au monde
si elle a parcouru le chemin depuis
atlanta en géorgie c'est pour ces
enfants
rallye est guéri brown thomas kg et je
veux leur apprendre à se battre pour une
cause juste dit elle ils sont égaux peu
importe la couleur pour un écran maxime
est lui a failli ne pas venir à cause de
la pandémie mais il a finalement pris
son masque et son courage à deux mains
convaincu de l'importance du moment h il
se réjouit de voir rassemblés ici des
américains de toutes origines
c'est un problème humain pas un problème
noir dit-il
et c'est tous ensemble qu'on peut le
régler peu avant midi ils ont convergé
par milliers aux abords du bassin devant
le mémorial de lincoln à washington une
marche contre le racisme contre les
violences policières décidé après le
meurtre de john floyd mais depuis
d'autres drames
d'autres noms sont venus s'ajouter à une
liste déjà longue dont celui de jacob
black
son père a du mal à contenir sa colère
ils demandent justice la date et le lieu
de cette manifestation n'ont rien à voir
avec le hasard car c'est ici il ya 57
ans jour pour jour
comment at'on loto quine prononcé son
fameux discours il rêvait que ses
enfants soient jugés pour ce qu'ils sont
et non pour la couleur de leur peau plus
de demi siècle plus tard
ses descendants ont repris le flambeau
avec la conviction que le rêve n'est pas
réalisé ce week-end son fils lance un
appel pour suivre le combat un combat
pacifique écrase bouichou scm et olé
nous devons nous unir pour éviter que le
rêve ne tourne au cauchemar d'utile pour
éliminer le racisme et l'exploitation
oui lewis lui essaie de rester optimiste
même si ce n'est pas toujours facile
dans le contexte il ya eu du progrès
mais chaque fois qu'on avance d'un pouce
on nous fait reculer de quelques pieds
au web comme tous ici
harry et ses amis place donc tous leurs
espoirs dans l'élection présidentielle
de novembre
par contre jean françois on ignore
encore comment ces tensions raciales
vont influencer les élections mais une
chose est sûre donald trump va pas se
gêner pour exploiter ce thème durant sa
campagne
parce que ça va rester un thème central
la campagne pour les deux partis
d'ailleurs même si exploiter de façon
très très indifférentes les démocrates
sont beaucoup associé à tout ce
mouvement pour la justice raciales
depuis le début par exemple on a vu
kamala harris faire un message vidéo qui
a été projeté donc devant les
manifestants rassemblés à washington
aujourd'hui ça c'est stratégique pour
les démocrates parce qu'il s'agit de
s'assurer que l'électorat afro
américains soient mobilisés qui sort pk
est votée et ce thème là de la justice
raciale et ben c'est un thème qui est
très porteur de nature à motiver les
gens à aller voter
orange il est important pour les
démocrates sur un même capital que les
manifestations soient le plus pacifique
est possible parce que il suffit que ça
dérape un petit peu et ça se traduit en
votes pour les républicains
et on a vu cette semaine d'ailleurs dans
le job mais pas seulement lui d'ailleurs
exploité ça il a dix ans et a agité le
spectre du chaos en disant que les
émeutes pouvait s'attendre à d'autres
paliers jusqu'à détruire devant lui
l'accusé aussi des démocrates 2
défendre des anarchistes et je le cite
les émeutiers et les pillards le dic
personnes en groupe 2 serait en sécurité
dans l'amérique de joe dassin message
qui va marteler tout le long de la
campagne dans tous ses déplacements
d'ailleurs était en déplacement au new
hampshire
aujourd'hui et alors que w c'est
simplement de ramener la conversation
plutôt sur le coronavirus sur la gestion
de la pandémie par dans l'ordre jean ps
pour dit essentiellement que personne
n'était en sécurité dans l'amérique de
donald job parce que surtout avec les
projections actuelles qui laisse
entendre que il pourrait y avoir jusqu'à
trois cent mille morts de lakovic 19
d'ici la fin de l'année
merci beaucoup jean-françois vous à
pleuvoir